ce qu'on propose va augmenter leurs
revenus
en même temps qu'en investissant dans
les jambes
le npd a aussi présenté son cadre
financier un gouvernement signe ferait
bondir le déficit à près de 33 milliards
de dollars la première année le déficit
descendra ensuite à 18 milliards à 16
milliards les deux dernières années du
mandat
le npd n'a pas de plan de retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
les nouvelles dépenses s'élèverait à
près de 34 milliards de dollars
les plus importantes sont
l'établissement d'une assurance
médicaments au canada 11 milliards 400
millions des services de garde universel
4 milliards la construction de cinq cent
mille nouveaux logements sociaux 3
milliards de dollars mais 5 milliards la
première année et plusieurs mesures pour
les communautés autochtones également le
npd va augmenter l'impôt des plus riches
et des entreprises sinistrées plus 50%
du gain en capital qui sera imposable
mais 75% hausse du taux d'impôt des
entreprises à 18%
une taxe de 1% sur les fortunes de plus
de 20 millions de dollars et hausse du
taux d'imposition le plus élevé sur les
revenus de plus de 210 mille dollars
pierre luc dusseault est le candidat du
npd dans sherbrooke pour son monsieur
dessous bonsoir monsieur fillion je vous
pose la question à vous aussi pourquoi
avoir attendu si longtemps après des
départs pour présenter un document
essentiel à la compréhension pour les
citoyens le cadre financier
ben je dirais que rien ne vaut dans le
cadre financier en soi parce que notre
plateforme été dévoilée en juin dernier
donc plusieurs mois alain dans les
premiers permis tous les partis donc on
se fait plusieurs mois qu'on est qu'on
connaît un opposition qu'on connaît
notre plan ambitieux et crédible mais là
c'est sûr qu'on entre avec le directeur
parlementaire du budget pour hervé
douris les tous les chiffres
et puis un cadre financier qui se tient
et pour sept des onze donne les mêmes
faits en fait on se donne les moyens de
nos ambitions dans ce cadre financier
mais aussi dans les devises d'augmenter
de 10%
quand même beaucoup plus de 30 milliards
les dépenses budgétaires de la première
année bien oui parce qu'il faut
réinvestir maintenant dans l'économie
puis justement ça va permettre la
stimuler puissent-ils assumer au bon
endroit puis on parle de meilleurs
services pour la population mais un soin
de santé entre autres
et ça va faire économiser d'ailleurs non
seulement famille mais aussi aux
entreprises
donc c'est vraiment d un plan ambitieux
et bien sûr qu'il va permettre de faire
beaucoup de stimuler l'économie mais
tout en étant responsable également et
comme je le disais tantôt on se donne
les moyens de nos ambitions donc oui on
va chercher
déjà venu il se trouve on a le courage
de dire bien les plus riches dans notre
société doivent faire leur juste part
doit faire un peu plus tendue que les
ultra-riches de qui possède plus de 20
millions de dollars en actifs en
patrimoine et doivent en faire un peu
plus selon nos raisonnablement calculé
dans vos hausse des impôts parce qu'y en
a beaucoup des hausses d'impôts dans
votre cadre financier sur papier ça peut
balancer ça peut être intéressant mais
la réalité c'est qu'on a un voisin qui
s'appelle les états unis qui baisse les
impôts
est-ce que vous tenez compte de la
mobilité des entreprises dans leurs
choix d'investissements et des gens les
mieux nantis aussi qu'ils pourraient
trouver des moyens d'éviter voros
d'impôts oui tout à fait puisque pour ça
d'ailleurs prend l'exemple des ultra
riches qu'on a on dit qu'on a on donne
un impôt de 1 % sur le 1% mais c'est
juste suffisamment pour qu'il n'y ait
pas à se déplacer par ça va coûter plus
cher déplacer leur fortune ailleurs que
la guerre d'ici l'entrée d'un avocat et
comptable oui alors c'est pour ça qu'on
leur demande d'en faire un peu plus
puis sinon bien bien sûr que il
s'essayait à considérer c'est pour ça
qu'on a pris d'ailleurs dans notre cas
de financer un fonds de prévoyance
parce qu'on sait que les revenus
supplémentaires qu'on prévoit d'autres
de 30 milliards de da peuvent être au
dessus ou en dessous donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a un fonds de prévoyance de 5000
heures pour nous permettre de quand même
atteint nos objectifs tout en sachant
que ya une possibilité que les revenus
ne soient pas toujours au rendez vous
mais bien que pour nous c'est important
que les plus riches
justement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure faire surface une part plus
importante qu'elle réduire les
inégalités d'ailleurs les quelques hibou
l'effet décélérateur d'une hausse
d'impôts surtout quand l'économie
ralentit déjà bien en fait bien sûr
contre en compte mais je voudrais que
dans les investissements confère et
comme vous l'avez dit de 35 milliards il
y en a beaucoup qui vont permettre de
réduire les coûts pour les entreprises
qui en parlent d'assurance médicaments
quand parle d'assurance santé meilleure
couverture publique mais ça fait que les
entreprises sauf beaucoup d'argent avec
des programmes d'assurances privées dans
quelle est comme une balance qui se fait
et on pense que pour les entreprises
c'est même gagnant donc il faut aussi
considérer quand on dit tout le temps
alors qu'on compare les taux
d'imposition des entreprises avec les
états unis faut aussi considérer qu'au
canada on est déçu par bons programmes
sociaux on est très compétitif le suivre
et s'est fait une différence pour les
entreprises qui regarde où ils veulent
investir vous et les légendes et
passante et ils sont bien servis mais
certainement pas de réviser les raisons
monsieur dessous mais en même temps on
est à une heure de la frontière on est
dans un marché très ouvert avec les
états unis même si c'est caen qui
parfois peut franchir la frontière
et quand les uns et les impôts baisse du
côté américain puis qu'on se demande si
on va investir à plattsburgh et
burlington dans l'étau new york ou à
montréal et qu'on a un gouvernement qui
augmente les impôts sur les entreprises
je sais pas jusqu'à quel point notre
rythme au pop facilement faire le choix
de la côte est américaine est pour ça qu
on tente de résumer aussi les coûts
reliés à lait ou aux charges sociales
des employés par exemple l'assurance
comme je disais médicaments l'assurance
dentaire qui des couvertures qui coûte
extrêmement cher pour les entreprises
donc pour nous c'est d'aller être encore
plus compétitif face aux américains ou
justement notre notre avantage
compétitif sont les programmes sociaux
forts et à public et accessible pour
tout le monde donc c'est la grosse
différence et je pensais compétitive de
voir des gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent et qui sont taxés jusqu'à 55 %
au québec parce que quand on prend la
table d'imposition du québec qui cite du
gouvernement fédéral
on serait rendu à 55% est-ce qu on
dépasserait pas une ligne ici mais je
pense qu'il faut regarder la qualité de
vie puis les services qu'on a pour notre
argent
quand on se compare à ceux parmi les
autres pays je pense qu'on a tout eu
tout à gagner d'investir dans notre dans
la société dans la réduction des
inégalités dans les meilleurs services
et programmes sociaux et je pense que
c'est ça encore une fois que ce soit
pour les particuliers ou pour les
entreprises c'est notre avantage et puis
pour garder la qualité de vie les
services qu'on a pas eu pour notre
argent nous on veut justement en donner
plus pour votre argent aux canadiens et
en investissant les programmes sociaux
et puis ça c'est vraiment la grosse
différence parmi les autres cadres
financiers nous on est on se donne les
moyens de nos ambitions oui on avait
misé encore plus on a plus de défenses
mais on a aussi les revenus qui viennent
avec pour investir encore plus plus
justement dans notre société
santé éducation vous touchez quand même
à des domaines de compétence provinciale
et vous reconnaissez aussi dans votre
code financier qu'il faudra créer des
partenariats avec les provinces donc
négocier avec les provinces
est-ce qu'il ya certains aspects dans le
fond qui sont loin d'être atteints
ça va être beaucoup plus compliqué qu'on
pense que d'atteindre certains de vos
objectifs
c'est sûr il va falloir s'asseoir avec
les provinces qu'on parle d'assurance
médicaments et soins dentaires qu'on
parle de transferts en santé il faut
s'asseoir avec les provinces pour
négocier l'entente donc bien sûr que va
falloir regarder comment peut on peut
faire ça puis au québec on a déjà
annoncé que on était prêt à s'asseoir il
y aurait une pleine compensation si le
québec veut se retirer de certains
programmes parce qu'on reconnaît le
québec comme état nation distincte
et puis que droit plus d'autonomie
danser dans ses compétences et puis mais
nous on est confiants qu'avec nos
plantes
par exemple l'assurance médicaments que
le plan avait tellement bon pour le
québec qui auront pas le choix
d'embarquer parce qu'ils vont tellement
économiser le grand risque à terme en
économiser sur les coûts d'assurance
médicaments et puis en plus les
entreprises du québec mon enterrement
économiser en plus des familles aussi
qui m'ont tellement économiser donc on
est et on est confiant qu'on peut
convaincre tous les provinces pour
s'unir pour avoir un pouvoir d'achat est
extrêmement puissant pour faire baisser
les prix des médias et des médicaments
n'est pas une récession au canada
bien sûr on est on bien en fait on veut
pas que ça arrive puisse nous ce qu'on a
on a un plan d'ailleurs de 15 milliards
pour la lutte aux changements
climatiques parce que pour nous c'est
une façon de contrer une potentielle
récession parce qu'on veut stimuler
l'économie du futur donc investir dans
l'économie du 21e siècle et technologies
propres la transition verte nous c'est
ça qui va faire je pense que économique
stimulée vers la bonne direction
et pas juste stimuler la croissance pour
la croissance mais la croissance
inclusive est propre
merci monsieur du tube pour cet
entretien ce soir ça fait plaisir en
droit